they will take their swings off the
right-hander dean kramer born in
stockton california 14th round pick out
a unlv by the dodgers
back in 2016 made his way to the orioles
as part of the manny machado trade
2-2 on the way breaking ball he got him
looking well that's how you get it
started right hander delivers and he got
him back-to-back strikeouts to start
this game
dean kramer pretty sharp out of the gate
man
let's fly to right field renfro back
back to the wall leaping and he makes
the play
how about that a little style there as
well for out number two wow he had that
time beautifully going back to that the
right field fence
in the right field wall
i didn't think he was going to catch up
to it the way he was going after it but
he had it timed perfectly
makes the jump and i believe the glove
hits the wall after making the catch it
does and he's able to hold onto it and
there it is
loves that
hayes did not like it so back-to-back
walks and the orioles have a couple on
with two down
here comes ryan
montcastle ryan hit a homer friday night
game one of the series
two on two down
first pitch swinging base hit center
field mancini around third he'll score
stewart
headed to third
and it's an rbi base hit for ryan mount
castle and the orioles go on top one
nothing
carrying his 281 average seven homers
into the left-handed batters bonds
there's a line drive into center field
devers pounds this one it's way back at
the wall gone
raffy devers ties the game at one
his eighth home run
straight away center field and the game
is deadlocked
hammered and a base hit
ricocheted into right field
and marwan will be safe at first
one two
and a bouncer out in front throw down
the line as gonzalez was off he's tagged
severino with the heads-up play
eliminates gonzalez cora with the hands
up they're gonna wait to see if this
call should be reviewed
gonzalez had been leaning away when
verdugo backed off the pitch took a
bounce out in front but it was enough
for severino to scramble pick it up and
take it and in fact they do tag gonzalez
off
and that one stroked into right center
field on the move mullins can't get it
it's past him up against the wall
dalbeck racing into second he's there
standing up with a double
a nice piece of hitting there going to
the
to the opposite field in the gap ready
for work two balls two strikes
[Music]
[Applause]
get well left field plenty of room
austin hayes is there
and the red sox are down in the fifth
they get a guy to third but no runs
we're still tied at one
pitch to mullins he swings hammers one
deep to right field renfro gives a look
climbing high climbing climbing out of
here cedric mullins with his six homer
out of the year in the orioles jump
ahead two to one in the fifth inning
[Music]
and they'll slap that to the outfield
down for a base hit so marwan with a
second knock today
leads off the inning with a single
that's where the red sox need get the
lead off man on
and a base hit
that one got past belaka gonzalez into
second base and here come the red sox
first and second nobody out
and the orioles
will make the pitching change dean
cramer
heads out with a 2-1 lead
now debra's two and two of the pitch
swinging a drive in a right field back
on it goes stewart he will not get it it
bounces up and maybe over the wall no it
stays in the yard one run has scored two
runs have scored and right behind
gonzalez comes verdugo and the red sox
put two on the board and lead it three
to two
[Applause]
[Music]
cracks a shot on to first and got him as
they double him up
marwan gonzalez catching that line drive
out of the air and then firing a strike
for the double play and as a base runner
not much you can do you know you're in a
secondary lead right there as you can
see and he knows he's gonna catch it he
just can't get back in time
you take a normal lead then you take
your secondary lead then the line drive
then you're out
swaying in a miss he put him away came
back in two strikes there and he got
mullet one man left others popped up two
times and grounded out to the shortstop
high fly ball center field it sounded
great off the bat back it goes yes in a
home run
under renfro with his fourth red sox
gets some breathing room and his 4-2 in
the eighth inning
hey show's butt gets drilled
that's what the worlds need is a few
base runners
that's back to back innings or put the
lead-off guy on
that's hit hard in the gap that'll get
austin hayes home
mount castle around first
and into second with a double
second rbi of the game for ryan
mouthcastle
and the orioles are within a run
abino with a 3-2 trying to get out of
the inning
ground ball scooped up gonzales up and
over to retire the side they get one
it's a 4-3 game after eight
well to the bottom of the ninth we go
orioles down one and
red sox bring in their closer matt
barnes he's been outstanding this year
16 games 1-0 and barnes ready to deal
his first one
[Music]
swaying at a high pop
into center field
gonzalez calling everybody off out
number one on one pitch
fastball and picked up by dalbeck at
first he gets to the bag
two very quick outs that ball hit very
very well
and if that ball gets by dullbeck you
get the tying running scoring position
at sega base but
a nice play by bobby d over there at
first base 3-2
there's strike three as he buried the
breaking ball the red sox win it
really nice win today 4-3
as they take the first three games
against the orioles on mother's day
the red sox victorious again
as they beat baltimore
4-3 your final score